let's face it nobody really cares about
desktop computers anymore
but that wasn't always the case in 1998
apple's mission was to get people to
care about a little thing called
the internet we are targeting this for
the number one use that consumers tell
us they want a computer for
which is to get on the internet so apple
came up with this bad boy
the imac fun colors
fast performance and jeff goldblum
well there's a computer it makes it so
easy you're up and running in 10 minutes
and you're still yourself
but now welcome to 2021 where this new
imac turns on in seconds
if that we care a lot about computers
now
just not the big stationary kind so you
can say this 24-inch imac has a similar
strategy to that original one
get people to care about desktops with
fun colors
fast performance no jeff goldblum
believe me i tried to get in touch with
him many times
dear mr goldblum will you be
in my video thanks joanna
with a new m1 chip beautiful display and
very good webcam
this imac is certainly more iphone or
ipad
than that 35 pound old monstrosity
but is that enough to convince a laptop
lover like me
let's find out let's start with the
design
because it's bonkers and there's good
bonkers
and then there's bad bonkers the entire
computer sits in this point four inch
thick rectangle
just look at it it's just a bit thicker
than an iphone 12 pro
yes everything that once sat in here
processor ram
graphics storage now sits in this thin
shell in fact it's so thin they had to
orient the headphone jack this way
because there wasn't enough room to do
it this way
like i said bonkers good bonkers
and this is all enabled by a new m1 chip
inside the same one inside the new
macbook air and pro
unlike intel power machines this is
based on the same arm architecture found
in chips in the iphone and ipad
it integrates the processor graphics
memory and more
onto a single chip which means less
space
some other things i like about the
design the power adapter magnetically
locks
the back there's an ethernet port on the
brick itself if you want to plug
directly into the router
and there's four usb c ports sadly no sd
card slot
you know what reviewers knocked this
thing for no floppy disk
it comes with matching accessories too
you have a choice of the magic mouse or
the magic trackpad
and just like the macbook there's a
fingerprint sensor in the keyboard
if you upgrade to the higher end
configuration that is but then there are
a few
questionable design choices here like
why is the screen surrounded by this
white frame i would much prefer it to be
black and i'm not the biggest fan of the
front pastel color options
i'd much prefer the darker color of the
back it's almost exactly like steve jobs
said back in 1998
the back of this thing looks better than
the front of the other guys by the way
plus how the hell does this mouse still
charge like this
look apple you know how to put a cable
at the top of a mouse you did it once
before
what is this on the plus side you get
this very nice fabric lightning charging
cord
okay let's talk about screen since
that's what this thing really is
the 24 inch panel has not a 4k display
but what apple calls a 4.5 k display
translation it's beautiful and crisp
with plenty of room for seeing multiple
apps open at the same time
take that 13-inch laptop possibly my
favorite part of this whole machine
the 1080p webcam thanks to image quality
optimizations with the m1 it completely
shows up the webcams on the new macbook
pro
and even the front-facing camera on the
iphone 12 pro in some lighting
conditions
so how does this thing perform just like
the m1 macbooks it's hard to get this
thing to slow down
in everyday usage web browsing with tons
of tabs
while photo editing listening to music
and watching a 4k video
no trouble at all for this thing wow
look at those graphics
the high end model i tested which is
priced at 18.99 with 16 gigabytes of ram
only started to chug when i threw in big
video editing projects in adobe premiere
i do recommend the 200 upgrade for the
16 gigabytes of ram for those who juggle
a lot of apps and web browser tabs
sadly you can't upgrade the ram yourself
like you were able to on this thing
those who want more power and a bigger
display will have to wait till apple
replaces the 27-inch imac
the company wouldn't comment on future
products but there are reliable reports
that will get a more powerful m chip and
an even bigger high contrast screen
so what do you do well i'd still get a
laptop for the freedom to move away from
this desk
though i really wish apple made a
monitor that looks like this
but if you're in the market for a very
sleek stationary computer
this imac is very good it's gif jeff
giff jeff giff jeff jeff jeff